now what's this what is this we've
actually looked at something like this
earlier when we were talking about X
sine X intention how to converge and the
origin remember that you had this
business of these two this two-sided
inequality here right well three sided
whatever do you know what it was called
it was called the squeeze law right so
it's where you've got this unknown
quantity right you've got in the middle
bear but if you can work out something
that's below it and something that's
above it and then you can get those two
things to get quite close to each other
they squeeze the thing in the middle to
some define value some well-defined
value okay sir how's this gonna work
well you can hopefully see what I was
doing as I was trying to expand this is
why your diagram is surviving on it
what's getting squeezed what's getting
squeezed it's the area underneath cause
X in here
right it's being squeezed between the
top trapezium from the tangent and the
bottom trapezium which is what you would
get if you do trapezoidal rule okay
because that's area believe you can okay
so that's where this is gonna fall from
right so to answer this question let's
start with one side let's talk about
what we have an expression for the area
underneath the curve right how do I get
the precise I fall into right what kind
of integral should I fall
posix2 pilot three of because that is
just cause right and I do it with
respect to X that were to give me the
exact area what is it cause goes into
sign doesn't it not negative side be
careful we're integrating not
differentiating okay
so therefore definite integral sine PI
over three minus sine PI on six right
okay what's this
three on to this aha
I can't sir now have a look at that
have a think how are we going to use
this result to get toward this right
well you see this root 3 minus 1 right
clearly that's going to be important we
need that there okay what could have
inequalities should I form which is
going to get me from this and this into
that what would you write there's a
couple of different places you could
start with
okay the area of ABDC
which ones that that's the one
underneath isn't it
so it's less than this integral isn't it
this okay I would say from the graph
well if you want to be on fancy and
sound like an extension to student you
can say by inspection I love another win
for you since right by inspection when
they're like I don't know why this is
just simple inspection okay so there's
my own you're like oh no we lose our
secret every day a few years there's the
LMU DC high of 24 root 3 + 1 um he's
less than 3 3 - what letter - okay now
how I look at it what I'm gonna do with
this thing
obviously it has most of the right
pieces in it okay life is 3-1 okay but
you can simplify in a variety of
different ways what should you do what
should you do to it and how could you
tell what you should do you have a look
carefully and what you're being asked is
proof right whenever y'all has to prove
something pay very very close attention
to it because that would guide the steps
that you do you're not just simplifying
any random direction you're getting
towards that so what direction should I
go in
ah I want to make pie the subject that I
okay because pi is the subject of this
inequality right so therefore here I
just have to divide both sides by r III
plus 1 and multiplied by 3 T 4 ok that
will give me PI on the left hand side
when you multiplied by 24 you get a 12
up to 12 right
there's also root 3 minus 1 and wonder
sound divided by root 3 plus 1 okay but
that's a bit awkward isn't it we can
rationalize that so you rationalize by
multiplying by the conjugate
don't you okay now I just ran out of
space gunky but you guys can see what's
going on when you multiply by the
conjugate which happens to be this this
will get square what happens to the
denominator it becomes 3 minus 1
difference of squares which is 2 and of
course 12 divided by 2 which looks very
encouraging when you think about what
we're asked to prove ok so now you can
tell me what I should do on the other
side what should I write from the graph
why didn't equality
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do the interval
and then I'm then I'll put down the
actual value so the integral from pine 6
to 5 3 of cos x right that that precise
area underneath the curve so it's not
equal to it's less than the bigger
trapezium C and D okay now I'll summon
my now you to let stand that mess there
PI root 2 on 12 what do I won again I
want to PI being the subject right so
I'll get these two guys over you have a
sign that 12 would go ever become a six
again right the root to go down the
bottom but again I should rationalize
shouldn't I right
did I get it right no wait something's
wrong tell these are two what happened
well I just have enough like that's
right of course 6 divided by root 2 this
is um this is 3 times 2 isn't it
so 2 divided by root 2 so there's the
pie over there 2 divided by 2 is just
root 2 3 2 is less than pi ok so maybe
if I wrote it round the other way it
would be helpful pi is bigger than 3
root minus 1 okay so now I have my
squeezed loss situation right hi
whatever it is 30 below this got to be
above this okay now it just so turns out
then when you actually took these into
your calculator which I went and did
okay what you get for these values our
last session get the real numbers you
get three point one five eight and so on
and three point two one and so on okay
yeah you like a bad coded like I think
maybe measuring your circle would be
better right because they're quite far
apart well let's just pause for a second
what are the numbers five hot but
they're relatively speaking well they're
far apart because of the values that we
chose here we constrain between these
two amazing
you can actually see what the error is
how would I go about making the error
smaller you've narrow in the champ
easier wouldn't you because then these
gaps they get smaller and smaller and
smaller why did they give you politics
in pilot three because you can handle
the numbers they give you something nice
and neat right but if we picked you know
whatever is really too close to the left
and planned for and one of the questions
right you get you'd start to squeeze
this thing in and you would get some
accurate approximations okay so I really
like this where the circles well there's
you know there's none geometrically but
the way the place where the circles are
hiding is in the causes and the science
right cuz the cause on the side the
that's where they're the coordinates in
the unit circle but the circles are
there that's why PI's there right but
it's um it's a clever way to see it so I
that's why I really like this question